All right. It is on the hour, so I will go ahead and kick off
this session. For me, this is not just kicking off the session, but it's also
kicking off the entire meeting. This is probably true for many of you.
So today's session is entitled Decoding Tumor Evolution through the Human Tumor
Atlas Network.
We have one introductory talk from a program
officer at the National Cancer Institute who will start out by telling you a little
bit about the Human Tumor Atlas Network, and then we have three scientific talks
representing three of the 10 atlases in HTAN.
There's no time for questions after the first introduction, but there will be time
after each one of the scientific talks.
So without further ado, I'll introduce our first speaker, Dr.
Indu Kohar, a program officer at the National Cancer Institute, who will tell
you a little bit about the Human Tumor Atlas Network.
Thank you, Hunter.
A very good afternoon to all, and
I thank the chair and the organizing committee for giving an opportunity to
present
and introduce our NCI's Human Tumor Atlas Network program.
It's not moving.
Okay. I have no financial relationships to disclose,
and I'm here representing the entire NCI HTAN
team. Members span across the various divisions
of NCI as well as within the
NIH.
We know that traditional hallmarks are the basic guiding principles for
malignant transformation of cancer from pre-cancer to advanced disease.
But these
relationships between these hallmarks are evolving, and the HTAN
program is addressing
such evolving relationship between the cancer hallmarks,
starting from pre-cancer to
late-stage disease.
Again, the deep understanding of the biology of the
carcinogenesis cannot be done
without the advancement
in the spatial omics technologies, and I'm here listing some of
the recent technologies which include spatial
transcriptomics, spatial proteomics, spatial metabolomics,
spatial multi-omics, and 3D/4D spatial profiling.
The NCI's Human Tumor Atlas Network program is a collaborative
initiative to map the tumor evolution at a single-cell resolution.
It aims to build highly dynamic three-dimensional
atlases of pre-cancer and tumor. The main goals include the
integration of molecular, cellular, and tumor tissue composition and
architecture involving the tumor microenvironment and immune milieu,
describe the transition across
the cancer spectrum, premalignant lesions to malignancy,
locally invasive to metastatic cancer,
responsive to resistant cancer type,
with the ultimate goal of enabling predictive modeling to refine detection and
therapeutic choices.
HTAN program was funded under two cycles, under Phase I,
which was from 2018 to 2024.
It encompasses various tumor types.
Six of them are listed here: lung, pancreas, colon, breast, skin, and
pediatric.
The highlights from the HTAN Phase I is published in a collection
in a "Nature" journal. It is a publicly available set of spatially
resolved tumor maps describing transitions in cancer for use by
the cancer research community.
Some of the important discoveries include one study which examined the
interaction among cancer as well as the non-cancer cells in six
different tumor types. The study identified distinct
substructures, which are called microregions, within the
tumors, which have been associated with different activities and interactions,
as indicated by a specific metabolic state or a T cell profile.
Several studies also focused on colorectal cancer, including two that
defined early molecular events that drive the
transformation of precancerous lesions in colon to cancer.
Two studies focused on breast cancer.
One used single-cell sequencing, RNA sequencing to profile metastatic cancer
from 60 individuals, while the other described the underlying
genetic networks that define the breast cancer subtypes.
Some of the common themes that came across these tumor types and analysis
include the recurring pattern of cellular spatial
patterns that is indicative of co-evolution of tumor and
stroma, which are emerging drivers as progression
of progression and resistance.
Additionally, discovery of rare transitional dedifferentiated or
plastic tumor cell types often conserved across tumor subtypes and
correlated with the poor outcome.
In addition,
the study addressed the deep exploration of stroma immune and immune cell
interactions. So far, HTAN has led to more than
200 publications and preprints, with 20-plus primary atlas
publications and 50-plus new analytical and experimental
tools.
So the findings of the HTAN Phase I
drives the implementation of HTAN Phase II, which was
initiated in 2024 and is still ongoing.
It is complementary to HTAN Phase I with respect to the diversity of
the tumor types. It includes PCA as well as HTA
center. PCA is the Pre-Cancer Atlas centers, which include skin,
pancreas, brain, gastric, and myeloma, whereas the HTA centers
include prostate, colon, ovary, lymphoma, and pediatric solid
tumors.This is the general structure of the NCI
Human Tumor Atlas Network, comprising of five BCA centers, five
Human Tumor Atlas centers, the HTAN Data
Coordinating Center, which manages the data, as well as the HTAN
Steering Committee, which governs the program.
In addition, there are several subcommittees
and working group, including Precancer Atlas Subcommittee,
Advisory Committee for Data Coordination, Methods Working Group,
Visualization Working Group, Translational Working Group, and Outreach Working
Group.
HTAN is built on four core principles.
One is the community resource, complement approaches,
open communication, and data and resource sharing.
Here, I'm showing how the HTAN data sharing and community
engagement takes place. All these atlases, along with certain
cross-network projects, generate huge amount of data.
This data is then ingested by the Data Coordinating Center that uses their data
platform and provides standards, validation, management, and
governance. The data sharing is facilitated by HTAN portal,
Cancer Data Service, ISP's Cancer Gateway, and Seven Bridges.
Further, the DCC, the Data Coordinating Center,
facilitates the community engagement through user supports, manuals,
workshop, working groups, and data jamboree.
This is a snapshot of HTAN data portal.
Here is the
QR code, which you can scan if you want to get more information on the
various data and resources and tools available in the HTAN portal.
As you see, there are 14 atlases now, spanning across 20
organ types with 2,400 cases and
approximately 10,000 biospecimens.
HTAN is not alone. It is part of a broader atlasing ecosystem.
It is collaborating actively with the Human Protein Atlas, Chan
Zuckerberg Initiative, Human Cell Atlas, HuBMAP in
various ways, through a working group, workshops,
cross-consortium metadata, as well as spatial biology
meeting.
How can you be part of HTAN? So HTAN basically offers
researchers which are not currently funded by HTAN the opportunity to apply
to join the program as non-voting associate members.
If you want to be associate member,
you please contact the HTAN Data Coordinating Center, email is listed here.
And that way you will be able to engage in HTAN consortium
activities through working groups, annual meetings, and
developing collaborations.
Overall, in summary, the NCI's HTAN program
is addressing tumor evolution to accelerate cancer
discovery. It is built for scale and collaboration.
It's a NCI-funded network comprising of tumor atlas
as well as precancer atlas centers,
built by multidisciplinary teams, unified standards via Data
Coordinating Center. It answers the questions beyond the scope of single
study, addresses tumor heterogeneity and microenvironment at
single-cell resolution,
builds multidimensional atlas from precancer through metastasis,
help identify biomarkers of detection, prognosis, and treatment
response,
additionally generates new biological insights and hypothesis.
It also provides open data to the community, which they can
use today through HTAN data portal.
With that, I'll end my presentation here. Thank you so much.
Thank you, Indu.
And as I said, we did not build in time after Indu's talk, but if you do have
questions, you can come up and introduce yourself afterwards.
So my name is Hunter Shane, and I am one of the
co-PIs of one of the phase two atlases, the
precancer atlas of skin cancer. And I'm thrilled to also
chair this session and kick off the scientific
talks for today's session. So I will walk you
through the journey from a normal type of skin cell known as a
keratinocyte, to a common form of skin cancer known as cutaneous
squamous cell carcinoma.
These are my disclosures. And if you want to understand the evolution
of cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma, you need to first start by
understanding what are the somatic alterations in normal skin cells.
And I'll pose the thought experiment to the audience, and that's how might you do
that. Your reflexive reaction is probably to just sequence normal
skin, and this is not a bad idea. But the problem with this
approach is that it gives you an average signal from the complex mixture
of cells that are there. Now, to be sure, this has been used to great success
in the past. You can go all the way back to 1994 when Doug Brash's
group used this approach to show that there are p53
mutant patches of keratinocytes in normal human skin.
And then, of course, Inigo Martin-Carrena and colleagues really turbocharged this
approach in 2015 in a landmark paper, to show more
generally the mutational landscape of clonally related patches of
keratinocytes in human skin.
But I would argue the ideal
resolution to do this would be at single-cell resolution.
In my opinion, single-cell DNA sequencing technologies have come a
long way, but they still suffer from low levels of sensitivity and
specificity in their mutation calls.
And so to get around this challenge, our laboratory developed the following
workflow, where we start out by extracting a bulk population of skin cells,
and then we single-cell sort them so that there is now one cell per well in a
96-well plate. We clonally expand these cells as much as possible.
These are cells from normal tissue, so they have a limited replicative ability.
But it is easier to genotype from a starting point of, let's say, 100 cells than
one cell. But to finish the job, we would lyse these small colonies of
cells, releasing their genomic DNA and mRNA, and then
further amplify these nucleic acid populations in
vitro.And between the combination of ex vivo clonal
expansion, in vitro nucleic acid amplification,
and a heavy dose of bioinformatics that I'm not going to go into, we are able to
call somatic alterations in individual skin cells at nearly
100% sensitivity and specificity.
I think the value of this data is best exemplified with an example.
And shown here is a skin biopsy that measures three
millimeters in diameter. I hope you can appreciate
that for all intents and purposes, this is physiologically normal human skin.
It came from the back of a 75-year-old woman.
She did have a previous history of skin cancer, as well as
self-reported high levels of cumulative UV exposure.
But this is normal skin from which we genotype 10 individual
keratinocytes. And the first thing I want to point out to you is that
many of these so-called normal keratinocytes actually have mutations
known to drive keratinocyte carcinogenesis.
This trio of cells has a biallelic loss of function NOTCH1
mutations, as well as loss of function mutations affecting
p53, FAT1, PBRM1,
NOTCH2. And then two of these cells further acquired yet
another NOTCH1 mutation. And then one of these cells acquired yet
another NOTCH2 mutation. And so if you're keeping count,
these cells have up to eight pathogenic mutations in the same
cell.
Now, if you had done bulk cell sequencing, you might have gotten lucky and detected
some of these mutations, but you would have never recognized that they were
co-occurring within the same cell.
Cancer is thought to arise after the accumulation of four to five pathogenic
mutations, and so we were somewhat surprised that these cells can
tolerate up to eight driver mutations, and yet that is insufficient
to form a discernible neoplasm.
Now, the second thing I want to point out is that many of these cells are
clonally related. I cannot say with any degree of certainty how
these clonally related cells are spatially organized, but we have drawn
a schematic here of how they may have theoretically been organized.
And this is drawn to scale if you assume that the size of each clonally related
patch of keratinocytes is proportional to the number of cells within it.
A couple things to point out here. It's perhaps not surprising that the cells with
pathogenic mutations have formed a patch, but you'll see that there are also
these two patches of keratinocytes without any apparent
pathogenic mutations. And not only that, they are of a similar size,
and I'll circle back to that point in a couple of slides.
Now, the last thing I want to point out to you is the extraordinary range of
mutation burdens of these cells. And you might not have initially recognized this
because I had to introduce a break in the y-axis in order to plot all this data
on the same graph. But these three cells with pathogenic
mutations have 40 times as many mutations as their neighboring
cells without pathogenic mutations. So what's going on here?
What's shown here is more generally the landscape of somatic alterations from
individual keratinocytes. And exactly as I showed you in the previous slide,
somewhat paradoxically, most keratinocytes actually have somewhat low
mutation burdens with relatively low proportions of
UV radiation-induced DNA damage.
But there's this tail of keratinocytes with extraordinarily high mutation
burdens. And when you ask what's notable about them, every single one of
these has an underlying pathogenic mutation, typically in the p53
or Notch signaling pathway.
So this is another example where had you done bulk sequencing, you would have
correctly deduced that the average mutation burden per cell is
around five mutations per megabase, but you would have missed the fact
that this is actually a mixture of cells with one mutation
per megabase and some with up to 50 mutations per megabase.
Now, this is a classic example of a mutator phenotype, meaning that
these p53 and Notch pathway mutations are causing those cells to accumulate
mutations more rapidly than their neighboring cells.
But are they doing something else, such as inducing a proliferative advantage?
And I'm not so sure that they are. So shown here is the inferred surface
area of each clonally related patch of keratinocytes that we could detect in the
study. And you'll see here in red, some have pathogenic
mutations, but actually most of them don't.
And the ones with pathogenic mutations do not appear to be any larger
than those without pathogenic mutations.
You can go back to the Martin Krainak paper, and they too noticed with a completely
different technology that clones carrying driver mutations do not appear to
be much larger than those without them.
So I'd be curious to hear anyone's take on this, but my take
is that these p53 and Notch mutations are conferring a persistence
advantage, but not necessarily a strong proliferative advantage,
meaning that when a keratinocyte has one of these mutations, it is less likely
to undergo apoptosis in the face of high levels of UV radiation-induced
DNA damage, and that causes them to accumulate mutations more
rapidly. Maybe they'll passively expand in
the space occupied by neighboring cells that do die out, but they don't really have
a strong proliferative advantage relative to those other cells.
So I've brought you up to this point, what I like to call the pre-neoplastic phases
of progression. What follows next is the premalignant phase of progression,
and in the setting of skin, this is a benign neoplasm known as an
actinic keratosis.
And in rare cases, an actinic keratosis can further progress
into a cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma.
And so in order to better understand these phases of progression, we assembled a
cohort of informative cases where we could identify a cutaneous
squamous cell carcinoma at that moment in which it was ostensibly growing out of a
preexisting and still intact precancerous
neoplasm, such as this actinic keratosis shown
here. We would microdissect and sequence each region, allowing us to infer
the order in which somatic alterations accumulated.
And much to our surprise, more often than not, these
neoplasms were not phylogenetically related.
So that's indicated in the scatter plot.You can see that there's these mutations
hugging the X-axis here. These are exclusive to the actinic
keratosis region. And then you'll see these mutations hugging the Y-axis.
These are exclusive to the squamous cell carcinoma.
If these were related, we would have seen some mutations in the middle here with
high allele frequencies in both the actinic keratosis and the squamous cell
carcinoma.
So this is what we call a collision.
These are just two neoplasms that just so happen to be near each other, but they
are not genetically related. But we scraped and scratched and
clawed and spent a lot of money on uninformative neoplasms,
but eventually we started to find a handful of cutaneous squamous cell
carcinomas that did actually evolve from the adjacent
actinic keratosis. When these two neoplasms are next to one another,
it's only about 10% of the time that they are actually related.
And this is one of those examples where you can see here clearly that there
are mutations with high allele frequencies shared between both the actinic
keratosis and the cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma,
as well as some mutations that are exclusive to the cutaneous squamous cell
carcinoma. So you can draw a phylogenetic tree based on this distribution of
shared and unshared mutations to deduce the order in which they
accumulated.
And here the actinic keratosis is driven by loss of function
NOTCH1 and 2 mutations, as well as a loss of function
p53 mutation. This is not necessarily surprising.
We know these mutations are common in normal skin, and they would, of course,
likely be inherited in actinic keratosis that grow out of them.
But we also saw a TERT promoter mutation and a loss of function CDKN2A
alteration. These are not so common in normal skin and
probably are responsible for the formation of a discernible
neoplasm. As for what drove the transition to cutaneous squamous cell
carcinoma, that appears in this case to be driven by a loss of
function ARID2 mutation,
as well as a hotspot mutation affecting the SIBL oncogene.
This is a well-established RASopathy mutation, meaning that it is known
to activate the RTK RAS MAPK kinase signaling cascade.
So that was just one case, but if you look more broadly across all the
bonafide cases of cutaneous squamous cell carcinomas that we could identify
that did evolve from a neighboring actinic keratosis, these patterns largely
held up.
p53 and Notch pathway mutations occur early and often and are
present at all stages of neoplasia.
TERT promoter mutations and mutations that disable the G1S checkpoint,
typically loss of function CDKN2A mutations, these seem to
emerge in actinic keratosis and are retained in cutaneous
squamous cell carcinoma. And then this is not obligate.
Cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma does not have to have a MAP kinase pathway
mutation or a loss of function SWI/SNF mutation.
But when they occur, these most often mark the transition to
cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma.
Now, because it was so difficult to find these informative cases, as part of HTAN,
we're now layering on multi-omic assays whenever we do.
And this is one example where we've done spatial transcriptomics
on a case where we know that the cancer was
phylogenetically related to the pre-cancer.
And I thought this was an interesting example because you can see here in
blue, there's this band of immune infiltrate that's beneath both the
cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma and the actinic keratosis.
But these immune cells could not be in more different states.
As you can see here, the cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma cells are expressing
high levels of checkpoint ligands, and concomitantly, the lymphocytes
in their vicinity are expressing high levels of checkpoints,
whereas there's not much activity in the immune
cells and the actinic keratosis cells above them.
And so this suggests that one major tumor microenvironmental change that
marks the transition to malignancy is the engagement of
immune checkpoints. And our hope is that as we sequence more of these cases,
we can begin to connect these microenvironmental changes to
pathogenic mutations that coincide with them.
So I've brought you up to this point from the evolution of a normal skin cell to a
primary cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma, but these neoplasms are
not done evolving. Approximately 3% of patients who have a
primary cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma will eventually develop
metastatic disease. And I think you can look at this number from two different
perspectives. On the one hand, this is a relatively good
prognosis compared to many other cancer subtypes.
On the other hand, this still leads to a lot of sleepless nights where patients are
left wondering how aggressively should they treat their tumor in order to
avoid being in that 3% who will eventually develop metastatic
disease. And regrettably, we do not have high-quality
biomarkers to predict who will progress to metastatic disease.
And so to address this gap in knowledge, I began a collaboration with a
wonderful group from Erasmus University and
SkylineDX in Europe.
They had assembled what is called the DeSquam study.
This is a nationwide cohort of nearly 45,000 primary cutaneous squamous cell
carcinomas with detailed clinical and histopathologic
information, as well as outcome. And if you study another cancer,
maybe this doesn't impress you, but in the United States, we made the regrettable
decision to not include cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma in our SEER cancer
registry. And so I don't even think this study could have been done exclusively in
this country.
And we took a subset of these cases for molecular analyses.
We constructed this as a nested case control study where half of the
tumors or cases defined as primary cutaneous squamous cell
carcinomas that over the next 10 years eventually
progressed to metastatic disease and half were controls, meaning that they did not
progress to metastatic disease. And we made sure that the controls were matched for
clinical and histopathologic risk factors, thereby ensuring that if we do
see molecular differences, they are likely to be prognostic above and
beyond common staging systems.
We performed whole exome sequencing and whole transcriptomic sequencing on these
tumors.Now, the first thing we did is we established the landscape of driver
mutations in cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma.
Another regrettable decision was the Cancer Genome Atlas project did not include
cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma among its cancers that were
profiled.
Also, cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma has an extraordinarily high mutation
burden, which makes it difficult to recognize driver mutations amidst the numerous
passenger mutations within each tumor.
And so our field had not yet even settled on a consensus set of driver
mutations. So this is now the largest analysis available.
We used Intogen to identify genes under selection and propose
here this list of approximately 40 genes, which we
believe are the main drivers of cutaneous squamous cell carcinoma.
But the main advantage of our cohort is that we have metastatic
outcome data on these tumors. And so we could then ask, "Are any of these
mutations associated with poor metastatic outcome?"
And indeed, many were. Loss-of-function mutations affecting SwitchSNF,
gain-of-function mutations in the MAP kinase signaling cascade, and
loss-of-function mutations in the TGF-beta signaling cascade.
These were all associated with poor metastatic outcome.
Now, in addition to whole exome sequencing, we also performed the largest
transcriptomic analysis of cutaneous squamous cell carcinomas, and after
consensus clustering,
there were three sample clusters and six gene expression clusters.
It was encouraging that the sample clusters did correlate with
outcome, one with poor outcome, one with favorable outcome, and one with
intermediate outcome. And when you ask what is driving this clustering,
there's a few different signals, but the main signal is the differentiation
status of the keratinocytes. As a secondary signal, there was a
change in metabolism.
The favorable outcome tumors relied on lipid oxidation, whereas the poor outcome
tumors were more likely to rely on glycolysis.
We were somewhat surprised that we didn't see an immune signal.
Now, if you look at individual tumors, there are definitely differences
in the states of immune cells, but it did not
drive, at this higher level, the unsupervised hierarchical clustering.
So it's encouraging that we can risk-stratify tumors
with this thousand genes, but that's an unwieldy signature
if your goal was to bring this into the clinic.
And so we distilled the signature down into a simplified version of
23 genes using a Cox net model, and you can see the list of the 23
genes here.
Generally speaking, these genes are involved in keratinocyte
differentiation, which is not necessarily surprising because this was the strongest
signal observed in the unsupervised hierarchical clustering.
But the million-dollar question is: Is this better than
our alternatives? And the answer here is a resounding yes.
When we compared the ability of this 23-gene expression signature
to risk-stratify tumors in an independent validation
cohort, that's a key detail. This is not just circular reasoning on the same
discovery cohort.
It dramatically outperformed Brigham and Women's and Health in the AJCC staging
system, and even outperformed a more recent EMC
model that was developed by my colleagues from Erasmus University
that takes into account more clinical and histopathologic factors.
Not only that, it works well in biopsies and excisions.
That's always an important detail to ask for these gene expression predictors
because you don't want a gene expression predictor that is tied to
surgical procedure or microdissection technique.
So in conclusion, we performed whole exome and RNA sequencing on the largest cohort
to date of cutaneous squamous cell carcinomas linked to outcome.
I said there was no TCGA project for this cancer, so we're hoping that this
will effectively serve as that TCGA project that never happened.
We cataloged the driver mutations and found that there are some that
correlate with poor prognosis.
We also performed transcriptomic analyses showing that
tumors with poor differentiation gene expression signatures have
poor metastatic outcome, and this is captured quite well with a 23-gene
expression signature that outperforms common staging systems.
As part of H-Stand, we're now layering on additional omic assays, including spatial
transcriptomics, hoping that we can find yet even more biomarkers within this rich
data set.
So with that, I'd like to acknowledge everyone that made this work possible,
particularly Barbara Renteria-Pacheco, the trainee from
Erasmus University, who led these studies, as well as my
European colleagues, Luz Holestein, Marlies Swakhuis, and Domenico Bellomo.
And then for the earlier work
on normal keratinocytes, Vishal Tandekar and Delaney Diveltern.
So with that, we have time for questions if there are any, and if
you do have a question, please come up to one of these mics.
Could you explain the
mutational phenotype a little better and whether or not it could apply
to many other situations, particularly the MSI high
phenotype where the MSI is acquired
or is a second mutation if one is inherited where
you don't know which came first?
Yeah.
The MSI is driving mutation, the high mutational
burden, maybe with a mutational phenotype, is
actually producing the second MSI hit.
Yeah. So I'd love to do a similar study in the set of normal colonic
epithelial cells. But if you forced me to
ask what's coming first, the chicken or the egg,
I'm going to stay in my lane and say, I think that the p53 and Notch pathway
mutations, and this is probably true for the MSI genes
too, that those occur first, and then these cells accumulate
mutations more rapidly. And in my particular case, I think that's justified
because the neighboring cells
without the p53 and Notch pathway mutations tended to have low
mutation burdens. But it'd be fascinating to do that in a colon.
Thank you. Ricky Peters, Fred Hutch.
You showed that
your signature with 23 genes performed better than the
other models, like the EMC, but also you said...
I didn't see the difference so much with the EMC, with the other ones,
it showed better performance.
Yeah.
Maybe I missed something.
No, you have a very keen eye. In the slide I showed you, there was a slight
difference, but what I was not able to convey is
that it was also complementary to the EMC, so
ideally you would do both. But the other thing with the EMC model is that
it cannot be applied to biopsies. It needs to be applied to excisions.
It takes into account
a large number of factors that
sometimes if you just have a small shave biopsy, that you're not able to actually
use that model. So we do think that for that reason, that there will be more
utility. But I'm a big believer in both the EMC model and the
Jebb signature.
Heinz-Josef Lenz from USC. I think these data are incredibly exciting.
I was wondering because at least in colon cancer, when you have one
mutation of KRAS in one cells, it changes the tumor
microenvironment dramatically, one out of a thousand cells.
Did you have a chance to look at if certain
mutations or mutation signatures changes the
microenvironment? Because it looks like it's all patches and
regionally determined, but is there a field
effect on certain mutations, particularly in the MAP kinase signaling
pathway?
Yeah.
As part of HTAN, that's the next frontier.
Unfortunately, the assays in the data I showed you were destructive, meaning that
we had to take the skin and
disaggregate the cells in order to measure the mutations.
And so then it's hard to go back and see what was their local microenvironment.
But we've cooked up some ideas, I think, that we could in situ see where these
mutant cells are residing. So, it's a sharp question. Thank you.
Hi. Farah Abdullah from Caris Life Sciences.
I know the point of the work was to look at normal versus
premalignant versus malignant. How does this or are there any plans you
have to compare to hyperproliferative diseases like lupus
or reactive
actinic neoplasms that are not cancers or precancerous?
Yeah. Again,
I would love to
do that. But I'm probably personally going to stay in my lane, which is
skin cancer. But
if we can get a phase three of HTAN, let's do it.
Yes.
Patrick Meeker, Uppsala, Sweden.
I'm a pathologist, and therefore, I was surprised
that you
did not find a relation between the actinic keratosis and
the squamous cell cancer. That
seems for me, totally surprising and not logic.
What is your resume?
When I first saw it, I was surprised, but
people who get
squamous cell carcinoma, they have
so many actinic keratosis, and
I think that once your skin just gets so sun damaged,
it's almost like your whole face is just one big neoplasm, and they're all fighting
and competing against one another.
I'm starting to see this more in other
epithelial tumors. I've been paying attention, for instance, to the
pancreatic cancer, HTAN, and they too have seen that a lot of the PanIN
lesions that are next to a PDAC don't have necessarily the same
KRAS driver. And so
maybe that's an important takeaway for those of you that are not
necessarily studying skin cancer.
If you see a cancer and it is adjacent to a pre-cancer, it's
not safe to assume they're related.
They might be, but you need to genetically test that. Thank you for the question.
Okay. I think we're running up on the question time, but really appreciated
all those questions from everyone.
So our next speaker is Li Ding, right?
From Washington University, who will tell
us about
her HTAN atlas on prostate and breast cancer.
There you go, Li.
Thank you very much, Hunter.
Okay. Good afternoon, everyone, and glad to see you all here.
Great turnout. And today I'm going to talk about
from pre-cancer to metastasis: evolution and
microenvironment of breast and prostate tumor.
Mm-hmm.
Going? Yes. First, I will provide a quick
overview of genetic drivers of tumor evolution
discovered by bulk sequencing. Then I will touch
on advances in spatial technology and the
computational pipeline for allowing us to
study 2D and the 3D tumor evolution and the
pre-cancer to cancer transition.
Lastly, I want to tell you about our recent work
on metastatic breast and prostate tumor in the bone
marrow microenvironment.
So back in 2010, we launched a study
to understand the tumor evolution in acute myeloid
leukemia to identify genetic factors
driving AML relapse.
So we conducted a whole genome sequencing of eight primary
and relapse pairs and discovered several patterns of
tumor evolution. In this highlighted case here,
this small orange subclone in the
primary tumor survived the chemotherapy and
became the dominant clone in the relapse tumor by
gaining additional driver mutations in genes such
as ETVC.So the beautiful fish
plot became a standard illustration for tumor
evolution studies in the later years.
So this study, along with others, prompted us to
propose a model. Tumor evolution is a stepwise
process driven by mutations in the oncogenic
pathways, including the introduction of
the initial driver mutation, then the addition of
cooperating driver mutation, leading to the formation
of the initial tumor mass, and then the addition of
progression mutation leading to the formation of tumor sub
clones.
So with the advancement in single-cell technology
and the spatial technology, we now can study
tumor evolution in 2D and 3D space,
and at single-cell resolution.
So the Human Tumor Atlas Network was launched in
2018 to build a 3D tumor
atlas from pre-cancer to advanced disease.
So in October 2024, the
H10 Nature Bundle was released. At WashU
H10 Center, we analyzed over
130 transcriptomes from
six different cancer types to study tumor evolution and the
microenvironment interaction in the 2D and 3D space.
This work was published as part of the bundle.
So from this work and other studies, we formed a
consistent bioinformatic workflow for studying tumor
evolution. From isolating the tumor micro
region using MORF,
detecting spatial sub clones using Calico ST and
other tools, and studying tumor evolution by
using a variety of software tools, including Mushroom,
a 3D neighborhood analysis tool. So tumor
micro region represent spatial cancer cell
clusters that are separated by the stroma
component. So a group of tumor micro regions
sharing the common genetic alteration, as Hunter was talking about,
then will form spatial sub clones.
So we were able to detect spatial sub clone
mutations using a variety of technologies, including
Visium and Xenium. On the left-hand side, we were
able to map this LDHB mutation to
the green subclone two using the Visium sequencing
data. On the right,
we were able to
map the LDHB mutant probes carrying
the mutation to the spatial subclone two
again, and the wild type probe to both sub clones.
So how about spatial sub clones in 3D?
So we build a 3D structure using multiple 2D sections,
as illustrated in this cartoon on the left.
So we look at the two topological matrices, mostly,
connectivity and the loop. On the right, you are looking at
an experimental 3D model for breast cancer liver
metastasis. So here we are looking at the spatial
subclone one in pink with three different volumes,
but with maximum connectivity of only three.
But now you look at the spatial subclone two in
green color. It's a much bigger spatial subclone.
It has only single one volume, but with maximum
connectivity of eight.
So with the experimental tool and the
computational tool, now we can study pre-cancer to
cancer transition in breast and prostate.
You must be wondering, why do we bring these two cancer types together?
It's not because we studied breast cancer in phase one,
H10, and prostate in phase two. It's because breast
and prostate cancers share important biological features,
including sex hormone regulation, germline
predisposition, physiological function, and
tissue architecture. Let me show you.
So the loss of the basal layer marks pre-cancer to
cancer transition in both cancer types.
Now, the question would be, what molecules and features
drive this particular transition?
So we created a complementary stacked and native
3D data set for studying pre-cancer to cancer
transition for these two cancer types.
This work was
accepted yesterday. Now it's online
in Cancer Discovery. You can get access to this
paper through this QR code.
I'm going to stay here for a few seconds.
Okay, so this is an example serial section
workflow for a breast cancer sample with both
DCIS, the pre-cancer, and IDC, the
cancer. So we conducted
44 sections across 460
micron of distance, and then we assayed those
44 sections using a variety of technologies,
including Xenium Codex, H&E,
Cosmic, and Visium HD.
So by expanding this approach to
multiple samples for both cancer types,
now we can map the pre-cancer to cancer 3D
transitional path. On top, you are looking at the
DCIS to IDC path for breast cancer.
At the bottom, you are looking at the normal gland to high-grade
PIN, then to the GP3 path for prostate
cancer.So native 3D night
sheet can help us highlight the complex structure and
connectivity of DCIS that can only be
inferred by stacked 3D. So the white
color indicate CK5 staining, and the red color
indicate pan-CK staining. As you can see, the
white DCIS dots are
embedded in the sea of the tumor.
So by combining the 2D and the 3D approaches,
now we can identify progression driver genes for this
pre-cancer to cancer transition.
We found some of the genes are enriched in the pre-cancer,
some of the genes are enriched in the cancer.
So those genes are involved in a variety of processes,
including tissue integrity, ECM
remodeling, metabolism, cell-cell
interaction, and so on.
So MGP, matrix gla protein, has been
found to be highly enriched in DCIS, the
pre-cancer, at both transcript and protein levels.
MGP binds directly to calcium and the
BMP2, preventing pathological
calcification of breast tissue.
So this function maintains the flexibility and the
integrity of the ECM, therefore preventing
transition to invasive morphologies.
So not surprisingly, when we lock down
on
MGP using shRNA, using a
DCIS cell line, we found enhanced
proliferation and wound healing.
So ERG has been overexpressed in a subset of
prostate cancer, as we all know. ERG
overexpression here has been found in
morphologically benign luminal epithelium cells.
In blue color, you can see the ERG expression
here. It's not surprising to see high ERG
expression in high-grade PIN and invasive cancer.
What does this tell us? This suggests TMPRSS2-ERG
fusion could happen way before we observe
morphological changes under the microscope, as
Hunter was indicating for skin cancer.
So in summary, we have identified unique and
common genes and the TME features associated
with pre-cancer to cancer transition for these two
cancers.
So the common one includes EPHA6,
GDF15, FASN, and MYC.
So due to time constraint, I will only be able to discuss
TME association with cancer transition, but you can get it
from the QR code.
So I want to use the rest of the time to talk about breast and
prostate bone metastasis.
So in addition of sharing the common biological
features, these two diseases tend to metastasize to
the bone.
90% of prostate metastasis are bone
metastasis.
To address this, we build a breast and prostate spatial
cohort for studying bone metastasis,
including both primary tumor and the metastatic
tumors.
So I want to draw your attention to this
linear plot here. So,
we can observe abundant tumor cells in pink
color, and we can observe abundant
fibroblast and macrophage in light
purple and blue color, and the
robust vasculature in the red color.
So when we compared the breast bone
metastasis to its
matching primary tumors, we found a subset of
bone metastasis show increased expression of this gene
called ACKR3. Another name is
CSR7. It is a regulator
of metastasis by interacting with CXCL12
to facilitate the tumor cell homing to the bone.
We have also found FGF receptor expression in both
the primary tumor and the metastasis, but with enhanced
expression in the bone metastasis.
So how about prostate bone metastasis?
We found enrichment of AR-driven program
as expected. You can see highly expressed AR
in the bone metastasis in comparison to the primary tumor.
We also observed FASN highly expressed in
bone metastasis,
enzyme involved in metabolism. And not
surprisingly, we found the canonical markers such as
PCA3 got lost in the bone metastasis.
So we are intrigued by the key steps of cancer metastasis
in the bone marrow microenvironment, including homing,
dormancy, colonization to expansion.
So when we compared the breast and the prostate
bone metastasis to the normal bone and to
MPN, a hematological disease, we found
the normal hematopoietic niche are replaced
by a tumor-associated microenvironment.
I want to draw your attention to the green box here.
You can see GMP, megakaryocyte,
MSC dramatically go
down.This is replaced by this
tumor-associated microenvironment, which I will discuss
in detail.
So we observed a significant increase in
osteoclast in breast bone metastasis
and osteoblast in prostate bone metastasis
as expected.
So then what's happening at the molecular level?
So
we found two very strong interactions
between tumor and osteoclast may
contribute to osteoclast activity in the
breast bone metastasis. PDGF-beta and
its receptor can promote osteoclast
precursor recruitment,
and TGF-beta I and
ITGB1 can also stimulate
osteoclast activity.
So when we look at the prostate bone metastasis, we found
SPP1 and the CD44 interaction and the
BMP signaling likely can strengthen
osteoblast niche in the prostate
bone metastasis.
So the SPP1 and the CD44 interaction can
enhance matrix adhesion, and the BMP
signaling can lead to osteogenic remodeling and
bone-forming activities.
So how about the vasculature and the fibroblast?
We observed a significant increase of the
vasculature in both bone metastasis, as
indicated here by comparison to normal bone and the
MPN.
We also observed a tremendous increase of fibroblast
in prostate and breast bone metastasis.
Most of those fibroblasts are MYCAF.
So we found in addition to the
well-established VEGF-A and the KDR interaction
for promoting angiogenesis, we found that
FGF signaling is also very strong in breast bone
metastasis, as indicated by the high
expression of FGFR2 in the tumor.
We believe this strong interaction might promote the
expansion of the breast bone metastasis.
So again, we observed this VEGF-A and
KDR interaction in prostate bone
metastasis. In addition to that, JAK1 and the Notch
3 and 4 interaction seems to be strong as
well, and this particular interaction can promote
angiogenic activation and vascular remodeling.
So now let's switch to talk about immuno cells.
We observed increased macrophage and limited T
cell infiltration in breast and prostate bone metastasis.
So when we look at the T cell stage, we found
cytotoxic T cells, although with exhaustion markers, are
more abundant in breast than prostate bone
metastasis. We observed comparable level of
Treg between these two.
So to fine map the TME and the tumor
relationship, we developed a density-based spatial
analysis strategy to locate the immuno and the
stroma cells from the peripheral of the tumor to the core
of the tumor.
So we found the increasing macrophage from the peripheral to the
core and the decreasing T cell from the peripheral to
the core.
When we dive deeper, we found that
breast bone metastasis were enriched with interfering
gamma positive macrophage,
suggesting a inflammatory microenvironment.
On the other hand, prostate bone metastasis
show the accumulation of SPP1 positive
macrophage suggesting a matrix remodeling and
bone associated immunosuppressive
microenvironment.
With that, I want to share with you a few thoughts.
Our study suggests potential new metastatic tumor
targets including FGFR2, fascin,
and others. Our study might also indicated
targeting some new interactions between tumor and the
vasculature could be a possible options.
In addition to the VEGF and the VEGF receptor
interaction in breast and prostate bone metastasis, we found
additional niche specific signals such as
JAK1/Notch 3/4 interaction.
A combined anti-angiogenic and a
macrophage-directed strategy is also
worth considering. Finally, immunoblocket
combined with macrophage-directed strategy could
represent another path forward. Breast bone
metastasis harbor an inflammatory immune
responsive niche while prostate bone metastasis
offer a immunosuppressive
microenvironment.
Breast bone metastasis may be more responsive to
immunotherapy,
checkpoint blockade, and macrophage reprogramming,
while prostate bone metastasis might require
strategies for targeting SPP1 positive macrophage
for improvingimmunotherapy
efficacy. With that, I want to thank my close
collaborators, Feng, Ben, Ryan, Russell,
Cassie, for their close collaboration for many years for
making this work possible. I want to thank my lab
members for their contribution to this study and to many other
work going on in the lab. Finally, I want to thank NCI
Human Tumor Atlas Network, H10, and
everyone here, Shami, Shannon, and my colleagues here,
Ying Du. And I want to thank CPTAC, PECDS,
and the Siteman Cancer Center at WashU. Thank you.
Hi, Ding.
I think the data are amazing. I'm a GI oncologist, as you know, but I wanted to
share with you some data we have generated on CSF1 receptor
as well as CD47. As you know, in colon cancer,
immunotherapy does not work in liver metastasis, but we
have shown that CD47, when you use that as well
as CSF1 receptor, you may overcome immune suppression.
So what you are seeing may be also applied for the tumor
immune suppressive environment in liver metastasis.
We have also data on FGF receptor 2 in colon cancer, which showed highly
predictive and prognostic features for outcome.
We have never looked for the association for bone mets because it's
very rare in colon cancer, but it's certainly linked to the
efficacy to each FGF receptor inhibitor.
So there are certainly interventions which have direct
implication for treatment, at least in colorectal cancer.
Yeah, that's fabulous. Thank you for the comments.
That's really
tell us about the commonality of different cancers.
Have you observed this interaction happening in the
colorectal cancer liver metastasis, although it doesn't go to the bone?
So there are data using a CD47 antibody that-
Uh-huh
... actually works in liver metastasis in combination with
immuno.
That's fantastic. Thank you.
Hello.
A very interesting-
Hi.
Oh, sorry.
No, go ahead.
Oh, I can go. So thank you very much, Li. Wonderful talk.
Thank you.
I was wondering, for those of us that are designing spatial studies,
should we do 44 different patients in 2D
or the same section 44 time-- I mean the same sample
44 times and build a 3D model? What do you think for a single
sample? Where do you think we're going to learn the most biology, through spreading
into the across many patients or building a huge 3D model of a
single sample?
I sense there are pros and cons for both, and
depending on what's your study design, if I'm
trying to figure out what are the
common drivers,
either tumor intrinsic or TME drivers for a
particular disease, I probably will do the 2D work spread
out for multiple samples. But if you are trying to
understand the cancer transitions, like what we are trying to do here,
a 3D model will be extremely helpful.
Thank you.
No problem.
Hi. Really interesting result on
your comparison between the gene expression between the
metastatic and the primary.
Mm-hmm.
You showed that-- I remember in the breast cancer, it seems it's
quite heterogeneous. Some patients upregulated
ACPR3, other patients upregulated
FGFR2, and still there are other
patterns. But for prostate cancer, it seems quite
homogeneous, or like everyone upregulated the
ER. And do you have explanation?
That's a great observation. You have really good eyes.
And
so indeed, we see more heterogeneity in
the breast cancer bone metastasis, although actually
for the breast project, we had the matching
primary tumor. And all of the breast tumors I'm talking about
here, they are ER-positive breast tumor.
So it's not like we are using different subtypes of breast tumor,
but we did observe this tremendous heterogeneity.
And for prostate bone metastasis, actually,
we have included both hormone sensitive and the
castration-resistant prostate bone metastasis.
We actually were expecting higher
heterogeneity from the prostate cohort, but we see uniform
expression for the genes I'm showing here.
But when you look deeply, though, when you look at the
interactions I'm showing you, I mean, I'm just showing you a subset of the
interactions, then you see tremendous heterogeneity in
prostate bone metastasis.
Thank you.
No problem.
Professor Ding, thank you for your wonderful talk.
The bone-directed therapies are commonly used in these two type of cancer, such
as Rank Ligand or RadioLigand therapy,
radiotherapy plus. So how would you speculate the
changes in the microenvironment TME or the tumor and these
genomic signatures if the
bone receive bone-directed therapies?
How would you speculate the dynamic changes of these?
Thank you.
This is a tough question. There are
always
a lot of different possible combinations for
treating bone metastasis because those
patients have already developed a primary tumor
and then develop metastasis. So they have already gone
through a lot of therapies. At this point,
I think
a single strategy would not be... possible.
And as the gentleman just indicated, how heterogeneous are
breast tumor, breast cancer bone metastases
are. So I think what you suggested,
plus some of the options I'm proposing
today, could
all be used depending on
patient-specific genetic alterations and the
patient-specific microenvironment.
Thank you.
Two quick questions and two quick answers.
Okay. I will try to be short.
Thank you for your talk. I had a question about
thinking also about the adipocytes within the bone marrow space.
You show a lot of metabolic markers, like FASN, you show
FGF2. So I was wondering if,
looking at the interaction, you would also consider looking at the interaction
between the tumor and the adipocyte, which is actually
promoting and providing the lipids for the
tumor.
Yeah, that's a great point. Although we did see
FASN, and to be enriched in
invasive primary tumor as well, but I think, yes,
the bone marrow microenvironment might further promote
the overexpression of those genes.
To be honest, we are still at the beginning phase of
analyzing the data. What you suggested definitely will be the
next step forward. Thank you.
Yeah. Great talk. Thank you.
Thank you.
Matt Leventhal from Dana-Farber.
Could you comment on the fact that, and I'm just curious what your perspective is,
on prostate cancer being seen as a slow progressing disease, but AR is
highly expressed and amplified throughout the life-
Yeah
... even pre-cancer. So, what do you think is going on with
AR going from the pre-cancer state to the metastatic state?
I need to answer that quickly. So, yes, AR has been
critical all the way, but
enhanced AR pathway really allow the bone
metastasis to keep going and that's
just the nature of the disease. And I will stop
here because I'm way over time. Thank you for the question.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you, Li. I'd like to invite our last speaker, Irene Ghobrial, who is
PI of the Multiple Myeloma Precancer Atlas from
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
All right. Thank you. I'd like to thank, of course, AACR for this wonderful
time and, above all, NCI and H10, because this has been
really a wonderful collaboration between all of the H10 members, and we've
been learning a lot from all of the different cancers.
So I'll take you through our multiple myeloma atlas and really
understanding the transition from precancerous MGUS
and smoldering myeloma to overt myeloma and how we can prevent it.
These are my conflicts of interest.
So if you think about multiple myeloma, it has two
well-known transitions of precursor conditions.
One is called MGUS, monoclonal gammopathy of undetermined significance, and the
other one is smoldering myeloma. And they're very different because MGUS is
very common in the general population.
Anyone over the age of 50, it's about 3% to 5% of us walking around
with it, and it increases more and more as we get older.
Smoldering myeloma, which is defined by having
10% plasma cells or cancer cells in your bone marrow, is the
next transition of that. And in these patients,
their chance of progression to overt myeloma to end organ damage is much
higher. So instead of being only 1% per year, now
it's 10% per year, so 10 times higher.
And in some of those patients, when we see them, they have something called
high-risk smoldering myeloma, meaning that they will go on to develop
end organ damage or overt myeloma, 50% chance in two
years. So when I sit down with a patient and I see them and I tell them,
"You have high-risk smoldering myeloma," I'm basically telling them, "You have a
50/50 chance of getting fractures in your bones, kidney failure,
anemia in the next two years." And yet we do nothing about it.
So we had a question, and part of the H10 was this: Can we be
more precise in our definition of who is high risk in the
population, and who are those patients who we should be treating early,
while others who may never progress in their lifetime, we should leave them alone?
And currently, the markers that we use are basically very clinical
markers. How much tumor burden you have, how many plasma cells you have in
your bone marrow, are they 20%? How much M spike you have, which is the
protein we secrete in the blood or light chains.
And these are really only tumor burden markers.
They don't tell you anything about the biology.
They don't tell you anything about the immune system or genomic alterations.
So we asked the question, should we really intervene in those patients
early? And we're trying to look basically like the solid tumor people, like breast
cancer. In breast cancer, we screen early
and we use mammography or colonoscopy in colon cancer.
Yet I can tell you in multiple myeloma, a blood disease, we can
use a very simple blood test called serum protein electrophoresis, and it's
much easier to screen by a blood test than doing mammography or
colonoscopy. And even when we find those patients with high-risk
smoldering myeloma, which is very much like a malignancy, like a Stage 1 or
Stage 2 breast cancer, we tell our patients, "Watch and wait.
Do nothing until you have metastasis everywhere, basically." Just like metastatic
breast cancer. Wait until you have fractures, bone disease,
or kidney failure, and then I treat you. And that's a problem.
That's basically saying to a patient with multiple myeloma, "Wait until you have
advanced disease, and then I treat you." So the way we were thinking of this
is can we diagnose those patients early and potentially treat them
early and shift the way of thinking into an early
interception?To do that, you need to be more precise
in your risk stratification. So I'll show you some of the work that we've been
doing with our H10 collaboration here.
And the first one was trying to understand the genomic alterations that can be
predictive of progression in our patients.
So here we took 218 patients with MGUS and smoldering
myeloma and compared it to patients who have already gone to overt
multiple myeloma, and we did whole genome sequencing.
And this is hard to do from peripheral blood or bone marrow cells, especially when
you have very small numbers of cells.
But we were able to find those alterations, and then we put them on a scale.
We wanted to make this something that's clinically relevant for our patients, so I
can tomorrow go to the clinic and tell them, "Here is your genomic score." And
we call that the MM-like score. And it's a simple score of how
many you have that are more MGUS-like, which is only 14, 16, or
14, 20, and how many are myeloma-like, which, as you see here,
NRAS, KRAS, 1q amplification, MYC alterations, and so on.
And you balance them, and if you have more of the one, then you're more
myeloma-like, and if you have more of the MGUS-like, then you're actually
MGUS-like, even if you have a high tumor burden.
And that's a critical one that we can now use in the clinic.
But we said, "Well, that's not really using single-cell level information, and
that's also not looking at the transcriptional changes that occur in the patients."
We know that many patients may have a 14, 16, or a 1q amplification,
and yet they don't progress to multiple myeloma.
There is something more beyond the genomic alterations of those patients.
So we decided to do single-cell sequencing with BCR sequencing
so that we can truly look at the malignant plasma cells versus the normal plasma
cells. And here we looked at 1.7 million
cells from 226 patients. And this was a collaboration with
Gary Guss at the Broad Institute, where we tried to ask the question
transcriptionally, what's happening in those patients?
But because those are the same patients, we also did whole-genome sequencing.
Another question was, what can you define beyond the DNA level and
beyond genomic alterations?
Now, this was a hard thing to do because we're now comparing tumor to tumor, but
also bone marrow plasma cells versus peripheral blood circulating tumor
cells, and we're also looking at normal cells versus normal cells.
And you can ask a lot of the questions here.
The first one we wanted to do is, can we look at those transcriptional
changes that occur during transition from a normal plasma
cell to an MGUS cell to a more malignant transformed smoldering
myeloma or myeloma cell. And you can see that we found 16
transcriptional signatures that were defined in those populations,
including cell cycle regulation, as you probably expect,
MHC Class II, checkpoint regulation, and so on,
circulatory capacity. But then we took those and went and tried to
see which ones truly predict for you progression to multiple myeloma.
And we found that six of those signatures were very critical for that
progression from MGUS to smoldering myeloma to overt myeloma.
And this is very critical, especially beta-2M, which is in the MHC Class
I. And you can tell that this is critical because we use beta-2M as one
of our predictors of progression in our patients, and the ISS
classification of multiple myeloma.
Now, we further validated that in the COMPASS data.
This is a larger data set that has overt multiple myeloma from
MMRF, and we indeed found that in the same signatures were
found even if you have overt multiple myeloma.
So this is not just the precursor conditions, but can also be applied in
patients with overt myeloma, even when they receive therapy.
Now, the next question we said is, well, that's good enough to have signatures, but
let's try to find a classifier that can predict for me, if I take a patient with
smoldering myeloma and I looked at their cells, I can tell where they
are in their transition from normal to MGUS to smoldering to myeloma
because the way that we classify our patients clinically may actually be wrong.
I may be classifying some patients who have MGUS that truly have more smoldering
myeloma in their transcriptional biological changes and vice versa.
A patient with 10% plasma cells, so I call them smoldering myeloma, but
they will never progress. They're behaving more like MGUS.
So can I take your cell and by single-cell signatures, tell
you where you stand in that transition period, and can I put it
in the axis of progression?
So here what we did is we tried to do a malignancy score and a disease score.
Malignancy score just tells me, are you normal or a malignant plasma cell?
And with 100% accuracy, we can tell at the single-cell level if this is a
normal plasma cell or a malignant plasma cell.
Then the next question is, what is the malignancy score as a
disease progression from MGUS to smoldering to myeloma?
And here we actually classified it from the MGUS and myeloma samples and then came
back and looked at it in the smoldering samples.
And we indeed found that you can create a score, we called it the MST score, that
can predict for you progression, and it correlates, of course, with disease burden,
with the light chain, with the M spike, but it can actually predict for you
progression, not only in the MGUS and smoldering myeloma and myeloma
patients, but also again in the COMPASS database, which is the overt myeloma
patients. And that classifier is critical for us because again,
beyond the DNA data, we can use it now in the clinic as a
classifier to tell us at the transcriptional level what's happening to the patient.
Now, the next question we asked is, can it add anything more beyond the DNA
level? I already know that my patients have genomic signatures, which is
the MM-like score. Should I add on it the RNA data, or is
just reflecting what happened at the DNA level?
And here what we did is we actually removed the DNA information because
we found very weak correlation between RNA and DNA from the same patients, and we
went back and said, "What is the transcriptional change that is occurring above
and beyond what you have at the genomic level from the DNA mutations?" And
you can find that the circulatory capacity, the ability of the cells to circulate
in the peripheral blood, as well as histone chaperone proteins and genes, were
critical for that transition, which tells you that there is a lot of work
to be done beyond the DNA level to really tell us why those cells become
more malignant, even in the early MGUS stages in our
patients.Because circulatory capacity and because the
CTCs, or circulating tumor cells, are so prognostic in our patients, and
we know that by flow cytometry, we went back and said, "Then let's do a larger
cohort of single-cell sequencing in the peripheral blood so that we can really
define what's happening in the bone marrow, but only in the peripheral blood." Can
I just use a blood sample from you and tell you if you have the
genomic alterations that are in the bone marrow?
And potentially, we can also stop doing bone marrow biopsies in
our patients because they're very hard to do, and patients don't like to do it.
So here, this is work that we did from 74 patients and 29 healthy
control, where we looked at both the bone marrow biopsy and the peripheral blood
over time, again, from healthy MGUS, smoldering, and myeloma.
And what we did is, again, with 1.2 million cells, looking at single-cell
BCR sequencing and transcriptional changes, looked at the tumor versus
normal and peripheral blood versus bone marrow.
But we asked a different question here.
We said, "Can I predict what happens in the bone marrow on the
FISH or whole genome sequencing data in a peripheral blood sample?" And here you
can see with this confusion matrix, we were able to predict everything
that you see in a bone marrow biopsy by FISH or whole genome sequencing in a
peripheral blood sample, even in some of those samples that had
some alterations that are not detected in the bone marrow.
It was because they had a couple of clones that were different in the peripheral
blood. And in fact, you can do that with only 10 cells.
And that was the SwiftSeq method that we developed to try and predict
progression in our patients, but also to give you value in a blood sample
with 10 cells in the peripheral blood.
Now, it's critical for us to think, as you always do, that tumor
cells don't live alone, and they have an ecosystem of immune cells, non-immune
cells, and the whole microenvironment.
So we asked the question, can we look at the immune cell signatures, again, across
time from MGUS to smoldering to myeloma, and what happens with an
early myeloma cell interaction with immune cells, and can we harness
that in the future for developing therapeutics, especially immune
therapeutics, for our patients with smoldering myeloma?
So here we took 877 tumor samples as well as
immune cells and tried to do a large atlas, again, of immune
cell signatures across the spectrum, healthy, MGUS, smoldering, myeloma.
But because we also have the single-cell sequencing of the tumor cells, now we can
look at the interaction between both of those types of
cells. So we don't have time to go over all the data, but I'll show you some
of the compositional and transcriptional changes.
And over time, you can see that there is a lot of compositional changes that occur,
including CD4 naive T cells, central memory T cells, including
Tregs increasing over time as you go to myeloma, CD16
monocytes, and you have less plasmacytoid dendritic cells and CD14
monocytes. But what was interesting, because we have the tumor cells, we
found a strong correlation between the cycling of the tumor cells and the
granzyme B CD8 TEMs. And that was
showing us that indeed, patients who are progressing from smoldering myeloma to
overt myeloma are the ones who have more of those granzyme B CD8
TEMs,
sort of trying to respond to the tumor cells and trying to respond to them in a
way that is basically exhausted despite being effector cells.
If you look at the immune programs in those and actually try to look not only at
the compositional changes but at the signatures across all of the immune cells,
you find that interferon signaling was present not only in the tumor cells but
across many of the immune cells, T cells, myeloid cells, and so on,
as well as other signatures that were correlating with myeloid suppressive
cells. And the other thing that we did was T cell
receptor clonality, and we tried to look at the TCRs
in those patients. And what we found is that as you progress to overt
myeloma, you have less and less diversity because you have very specific
sub-clones of T cells that are responding potentially to those tumor
cells. And we're now trying to look at all of those TCR clones that are
expanding and responding to the tumor cells.
Now, what else are we doing with the spatial question with the H10?
Here we're trying to take all of this information and take it at the spatial
transcriptomic and proteomic level.
And to understand that, as we know very well, the bone marrow biopsies that we do
in our patients are very hard to actually look at them because we do
decalcification, which actually messes up all of your DNA and RNA, and then we put
them in paraffin-embedded, and then we try to say, "Let's try to do what the solid
tumor people do." But it's very hard to do that in bone marrow biopsies.
But bone marrow biopsies are very critical because all of the data I showed you
in bone marrow aspirates, which is what we pull first from the first pull of our
patients, does not reflect everything that's happening.
It's not just the spatial localization of the cells and how they interact with
each other. You're also missing a lot of the stromal cells, adipocytes, as
we talked about, endothelial cells, and so many other
architectural changes that occur in the bone marrow.
So we spent a lot of time trying to develop a spatial proteomic method, and here
we used IMC, which is imaging mass cytometry,
and we developed 36 antibodies that would work on IMC that we
validated by immunohistochemistry and immunofluorescence to make sure indeed
they work on a decalcified bone marrow biopsy.
And you can see here that we have CD3 and CD138, then you can classify it
as T cells and myeloma and so on, and finally have enough
signatures of all of your tumor cells and immune cells to ask those
questions. So when you look at all of this data, we started seeing that
adipocytes, actually, because you lose them a lot when you're doing all of those
cuts and decalcification in your bone marrow, we couldn't even call
the adipocytes, and we couldn't call megakaryocytes because they're too big.
So we had to develop a new package, which is available, called the AdipoFinder,
where you can actually recapitulate the data of the adipocytes,
and now look at all the cell-to-cell interactions in those patients.
And we decided to look in a study of 98 samples of
CAR-T, either cell or silta cell, so patients with multiple
myeloma who received the cellular therapy, CAR-T.
If I take their sample before going on the CAR-T therapy, can I
predict whether they will respond to therapy or not?
And can I predict their toxicity? These are very critical questions
for us clinically.So the first thing we did is we started to look at those
cellular neighborhoods, cell-to-cell interaction between myeloma cells,
immune cells, and others. And it's very important to show that
indeed it's not just any change that occurs in the bone marrow.
The cells actually do sit in very specific cellular neighborhoods,
and it's very similar to what we see in solid tumors.
So when we look at those cellular neighborhoods and put them together, we start
seeing indeed that some of those neighborhoods are actually predicting not only a
progression-free survival to CAR T, but also overall
survival in our patients. And many of those signatures were not just about
tumor burden, which is in red here, the plasma cells or the tumor cells, they were
also about the mixture between the tumor cells and the immune cells.
So here is an example of how a tumor and immune cell interaction
occurs, and sometimes it gives you a very bad prognosis, and sometimes it gives you
a very good prognosis, which are very different depending on the types of
myeloid cells or tumors to immune cell interaction that are sitting
in that cellular neighborhood.
And finally, we said it's not just about response to therapy, but also the
cytokine release syndrome and the prolonged cytopenias that we see with our
patients. Many of them may not recover their counts for a long time.
Can we look at that inflammation that occurs in the microenvironment, and can we
predict with accuracy that those patients will have potentially that
inflammation, CRS, or prolonged neutropenia because we can potentially
prevent it? And indeed, you can find that specific interactions
between myeloid cells,
and dendritic cells can predict for us prolonged neutropenias in
our patients.
So finally, why do we do all of this?
We do this because we want to treat our patients.
And I can tell you finally, we have the first FDA-approved drug for
smoldering myeloma, which is daratumumab.
But that's the beginning, not the end.
And in fact, we want to actually improve things by using
immunotherapy in our patients with smoldering myeloma.
And to do that, we've done two clinical trials as a proof of concept that
indeed you can make a difference by treating early and by harnessing the immune
system with cellular therapy or bispecific antibodies.
So here with a bispecific antibody called teclistamab versus LenDex, which is
our traditional way of treating smoldering myeloma, we compared those patients
and treated them to see if truly our hypothesis is
true that your immune system is better in the earlier
stages, that your tumor burden and your clonal evolution is not as
extensive as it is in overt myeloma, then you should probably have an amazing
response if you use your best therapy, immunotherapy, as early as
possible. So with that, we showed the first data of the first 12
patients, but the study is completed, so hopefully we will show the rest of the
data soon. But this shows you the first proof of concept that a
bispecific antibody, a T-cell engager, showed us
100% response rate, 100% MRD
negative disease, which means there's no evidence of tumor cells in the first
12 patients, and with less infections and less cytokine
release syndrome compared to the overt multiple myeloma.
And here is one of our patients. This was patient number two, and you can see his
light chains were significantly high.
And after just receiving the first few doses of teclistamab, you can see
complete resolution of his lambda light chain, and it's still in an
MRD negative disease three and a half years later.
And he sent me this picture when he was bungee jumping in New Zealand, so I'm using
this as the best quality of life measure for patients who are on a bispecific
antibody.
Now, the other study, which was also the hardest thing to do, was
can we convince the FDA and pharmaceutical companies to give us
cellular therapy, CAR T therapy, not in the relapse refractory
setting, not in the newly diagnosed, but in smoldering, in asymptomatic patients.
And I can tell you this will be a plenary session Monday morning, so please come
and visit and hear us talking about it, of 20
patients who Omar Nadeem will be presenting with CAR T.
But we showed the first six patients a couple of years ago, or
actually last year in the American Society of Hematology.
And this is a teaser for what you're going to see Monday.
But again, 100% MRD negative disease with one and done
cellular therapy, which tells you again that the proof of concept matters if you
use your best therapy or immunotherapy and you use your T-cell engagers
early on. So with that, I hope I took you through a journey
of precursor multiple myeloma. Can we diagnose them early?
Can we risk stratify them with genomic, with immune, with single-cell
sequencing, and spatial transcriptomics and proteomics to really
define those patients who will benefit from therapy?
And then can we apply our best therapeutics, especially immunotherapy, in
those patients to potentially intercept and cure our patients with myeloma?
With that, I'd love to thank, of course, our lab members, clinical members, all our
funders, Gaddy Getz, who all our work we do it in collaboration with him.
And above all, our patients. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the talk. It was super nice.
Well, you said that you had BCR data for
the single-cell analysis, and as far as I know, this premalignant
condition can be kind of oligoclonal from the BCR
level. Have you looked at it? Do you observe this oligoclonality?
And if you do so, do you see differences in these
scores from progressing to myeloma?
Yeah, great question. So yes, all of our samples have BCR sequencing.
And in fact, the more you go towards malignancy, the more there is a major
BCR clone. And this is true also when we do VDG sequencing for
adaptive. You may have other subclones, smaller subclones, but most of
the time it's a major one clone. But you're right.
And we have other studies that I didn't show here called MGAP, which is the
very early event of a change of monoclonality, and you
do see those oligoclonal cells, and they compete with each other until one of them
actually becomes the major clone.
This was not a journey, this was a rollercoaster.
It was incredible.
I know that multiple myeloma is also classified by significant
hypomethylation. So we heard about transcriptomics and DNA.
What is methylation play a role in the characterization and
outcome for multiple myeloma?
Yeah, great question. I think we are deficient in a lot of the epigenetic
regulation, methylation, and so on, and we do definitely need to do more.
There has been many studies, but not enough and not at the single-cell level.
So absolutely, we need to do that.
Okay. If there are no more questions, I want to thank the speakers
for keeping us on time and for these great talks, and thank you,
audience, for all of your questions.
If you have any questions that you were too shy to ask, you can feel free to come
up and introduce yourself afterwards. That closes today's session. Thank you.